[Music]  ladies and gentlemen  thank you so much for flying with us  [Music]  we went back to his hotel  [Music]  [Music]  he was so alive  i can't remember anything about it yes  i'm your best friend so i have to ask  why'd you clean it up i  i don't know okay uh  just kissed up thinking how that guy in  3c died  the flight attendant she knows more than  she's saying  the fbi wanted information about you i'm  gonna keep digging  do not do anything stupid  did you bring me to 3c's funeral  you weren't a suspect before you sure as  hell are now how many drinks have you  had today i'm a crazy drunk flight  attendant  not a killer what did you get me  involved  [Music]  [Music]  you